good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast and happy Monday hope
everybody had a great weekend um Jack or
should I say Misa Misa if you're
listening to these episodes in
succession I left you on a cliffhanger
on Friday what am I doing if you're not
listening to these episodes in
succession what are you doing oh of
course but maybe someone listened on
Friday waited two days and Monday but
maybe some people saved Friday's episode
and they're going right into Monday
which is how I like to consume contents
sometimes I don't have to end on a
cliffhanger this weekend I went to
Disney World in Orlando Florida with my
family Olivia and her family it was the
trip of a lifetime now to be clear let's
just clear up some rumors before they
get started okay you went with your
children you were not Disney adulting
around the park I mean I know you know
you know the consequences of of what you
do you never know what's going to happen
it did turn out that our eldest sister
Olivia actually is a Disney adult became
a Disney adult she didn't know either it
kind of took over the spirit of the
Disney adult took over for troud skin
but yes we took our families we weren't
just like adults picking up and deciding
to go to Disney it was for the kids they
love a lot of the Disney characters and
we felt that they would really get a lot
if we did it and we went of course so I
had said on the show a few weeks ago
that like Disney was in our future this
season and we we made it happen
and how do you feel now you got home
last last night I got home last night I
feel broken physically mentally
everything I feel accomplished of course
of course I feel happy oh she feels
happy I feel full of memories and good
times and food cuz the thing about
Disney is like you're either starving or
you're about to puke because the only
food that you can get there is just
so gluttonous but like they don't tell
salads they actually do sell salads but
you can't customize no
dressing oh not very accommodating
Disney Parks no that was one of my
thoughts or critiques about the park
like there really isn't healthy food and
it's just like why you have literally
everything there it's not like there's
no expense spared at the dis yeah yeah
at the dis okay so I know you did the
fireworks show I know you did the Mickey
parade you were limited of course in
what rides you could do cuz you know
with small kids but highlights low
lights best part worst part so the high
highlights for me were the things that
the kids enjoyed most and I guess
surprisingly what the kids enjoyed most
was like the shows the parade just like
seeing the characters Mickey and his
friends like come on stage at the castle
at Magic Kingdom uh like once an hour
once every two hours and they do this
little like dancing show and Harry that
was his the best thing that he saw and
like that wasn't even on our schedule we
just happened to be walking by and saw
it so for kids their age like really the
parade was amazing um there was actually
another parade that we saw there was
Mickey's Phil har magic which was a
little like magic show movie type of
thing really really cute so the things
where they could like see the characters
they love the best the rides a lot of
waiting a little payoff yeah well I
remember going as a child and I remember
meeting the characters whom I of course
had come to know and love on my
television screens and actually being
like freaked out and like not excited
but scared but they're like enormous
compared to and I just remember being
like scared of them they weren't scared
but they were definitely you would never
know that like Harry like is obsessed
with Mickey he was playing it super cool
like oh hi Mickey you want to hug my mom
like I have a by the way I have a memory
of meeting The Lion King um character I
think uh who was it maybe Rafiki and
like hysterically crying yeah it could
be overwhelming then we stumbled we were
at Epcot the Third on Sunday and we were
just like walking in this area and they
were like are you here for Daisy and I
was like no we're just taking pictures
and then I'm like oh my gosh it's Daisy
Duck like Donald's wife da daffy's wait
Donald's wife Daisy and who's Daffy Duck
she's from Looney Tunes oh she's not
affiliated with this family okay my bad
my bad so we're like oh [__] like Daisy
and we're at the front of the line so we
like we're like okay yeah well me Daisy
the kids love the Ducks and then they
come out she's like running late they're
like Daisy's running a little late and
we're like okay Daisy they're like
Daisy's having a fashion emergency she
won't be here for an hour and a half
like where the [__] was
Daisy wait what's the T she was drunk
she was hung over Daisy was drunk Daisy
was caught drinking on the job and up
until that point I was going to say like
the park
runs so like a well oiled machine
smoothly so amazing it's incredible the
amount of people that go through the
park every single day or every single
year like for the volume there's really
not that much charge and not that much
waiting and like the lines for security
like they move everything moves it's not
love that it's not so painful and
everything was so on time even you do
like the genie app and the lightning
lines and everything really moves and
that was the first hicup we had cuz like
I need to know what was going on with
Daisy like I just need to know now let
me ask you a question now a lot of
adults who go to Disney not Disney
adults adults who go to Disney with
their children really Marvel at the uh
the drinks like apparently Disney's
really known for its cocktails but you
were with your kids and I know you don't
really drink but like did anybody have a
cocktail the First Night Olivia I'm
putting together like a little reel from
the trip so you'll be a and you guys by
the way you guys are going to record a
podcast right we are going to record a
podcast because we have so many funny
stories from the trip so it'll just be
fun to like rehash it and then also
we'll take some questions if you want
tips for going to Disney because Olivia
is officially a Disney expert she could
be a Disney tour guide she study she was
giving us all these like fun facts about
Disney about the history like why Epcot
is called Epcot why is it called it
stands for like
experiential places countries like it's
it stands for something it was meant to
be like something uh a futuristic vision
of the world C and obviously when we're
now living in the future and it doesn't
really look like that but Epcot was not
what I expected it was like kind of
giving zen garden no the best thing to
come out of your trip to Disney is like
this inside family joke that Olivia is a
Disney adult Olivia by the way it's
worth mentioning because I don't want to
disgrace her name like Olivia would
absolutely never go to Disney like by
choice without her kids until this
weekend no no no I'm saying future had
oh like no I don't think she would go
again like without her kids well no she
would have bring her kids cuz it's like
what are they doing what would she be
doing without but like if something if
for some reason she had to go to Disney
without her kids and like adult I think
she would love it oh wow that's a Haus
accusation yeah no I'll I'll have her
respond to these charges but it was
funny because she was doing all the like
lightning lanes and the genie and the
first ride that we did of our trip was
this Peter Pan ride which they said is
like the best for kids of all ages and
the line was really long and we were
like and this was the first thing we
were doing and it kind of set like a bad
precedent we're like this is supposed to
be a lightning Lane and throughout the
weekend we were like yeah but Peter Pan
line was long and she was like that's
not how the genie app is supposed to
work when it works right it will not be
like that and Shapiro was like did you
work on the team that built the genie
app like she was so defensive of Genie I
just want to say I have absolutely no
fomo from like you guys going to
Disneyland but I can imagine how much
you guys were just like poking fun at
one another and laughing so hard and
like that gives me fomo laughing so hard
and we I came away with the conclusion
that Olivia and my husband actually
really thrived at Disney like brought
out the best in them they took it all on
gracefully
positively yeah conversely Shapiro and I
no I could see Disney bringing out
lowest in Shapiro we are not of the
Disney
[Laughter]
elk Shapiro and I were not of the Disney
Disney G I would have loved to have
watched like a reality show episode of
you guys the Disney like so funny well
that will be when Olivia and I podcast
we will share all the highs and lows but
it really it's the most magical place on
Earth but what's so funny is like you go
from the highest of highs like just
watching your child like it's magical
it's really truly magical to then like
the lowest of lows like brink of
divorce no that's so relatable not
letting your child see this low point
that the misery yeah
yeah and I just want to say needed that
belly laugh that is funny every family
that's walking around there like every
parent who's it's a universal experience
yeah no and I just want like the parents
who are there taking their children like
you are amazing parents like you're
amazing and and by the way if you don't
take your kids to Disney you're also
amazing okay calm down
um just like you could go you're being
so funny today you go to Disney and like
just sit and watch people like I didn't
have the time to watch people cuz I have
to watch my own children but like a Solo
Traveler could just go and watch it
would be like an anthropological
experience to watch these couples
breaking down in
[Laughter]
real totally so I kind of want to go now
like no you should go and also what it
was reminding me of a little bit like
with the outfits and everything like
these 3day experience tour no it was
like adult a family version of Coachella
it's like what are the outfits going to
be okay I'm going to wear my best outfit
on Saturday the full day well I do want
to say you guys planned inadvertently to
go at an amazing time where you're
experiencing a cold front in Florida and
like I saw you guys wearing hoodies yeah
no the kids were wearing gloves bundled
up in uh iess it's not great for it's
guess it's not great for the kids but
like for the adults imagine if you had
to do all of that in like shorts and 90°
weather no no no but what's so weird is
that the weekend we went was they say
one of the least busy weekends of the
year but I don't know why people
wouldn't want to go in the cold duh so
the mornings it would be like less than
50 there so the kids wor jackets but
then it warmed up over the course of the
day so the jackets come off and it was
like beautiful beautiful weather but
like Friday night I was like okay I'll
go in my like athleisure look like you
know not trying too hard then Saturday
Balls to the walls like it's really the
way I was planning outfits Co it felt
like Coachella okay how wear his best
fit on Saturday when doing like you know
Mickey's headlining and then Sunday
casual heading home you know not trying
too hard chill yeah yeah that is so
funny I'm so glad you made it out alive
I'm so glad everybody had a good time
I'm so glad that we did it and now that
we know what we're doing a lot of
mistakes were made by me and my what
would you say is your biggest and I
don't want to spoil the patreon because
you guys are going to do a whole podcast
episode but what would you say is your
biggest mistake like if you could part
some wisdom to Future parents going the
mistakes that I made I don't think other
people like I we made some really dumb
moves Zach and I like just in you going
to share them I'll we'll talk about them
on the episode because it's just like
but not not even in planning like in
driving like we were just being stupid a
little bit honestly oh wow okay well if
you can own it yeah no we were being
stupid because like we were blindly
following Olivia and like she's not a
mind reader and she couldn't predict how
stupid we were going to
be okay yeah so you'll get all the drama
on the patreon but no no regrets just
even being they like walking down the
street it's magical yeah yeah no I get
it and especially you you see it through
your kids eyes yeah and I started a
little list on my phone of like lessons
of things that I would do differently
next time aside from like the dumb human
errors that I made like packing a lunch
for the kids because the thing is like
it's so hard to get food there and when
you decide you want to eat like then
it's still another like 30 40 minutes
until you get your food and like they
can't wait that long so it just be nice
to like have had also like healthy
balanced meals for them and and just
like in a little bento lunch Bo like
nothing crazy like a sandwich so that
they could eat whenever they were hungry
and we could carry on it wouldn't just
be like oh my God the kids are falling
apart and we can't get food no and like
the whole day stops yeah yeah yeah I get
that so lot of lessons and I think
Olivia and I will put our heads together
on the patreon and like come up with
another list and I have a note on my
phone so that next time like I don't
have to remember and it'll be just there
maybe we'll become like Disney annual
passholders I was going to say as
Florida residents what do you think with
children
what do you think is like an appropriate
amount of times per year to go to Disney
I don't know I'd have to ask the class
like maybe for us because like for other
people maybe more maybe for us like
twice it it depends I'll talk to Trout
but Florida residents do get discounted
passes I heard I guess cuz our tax money
like might in some way go towards Disney
because it's like a tour has yeah and it
has special perks in the State of
Florida it's actually very cool that
Disney itself it feels like it's own
city which by the way by way the last
time I went which was one of the worst
experiences of my life I thought the
same thing whoever runs Disney like
should be the mayor or the president
because it run smoothly I didn't see any
crime the streets were clean the clocks
were on time like really really a
well-run city but Olivia was telling us
that it's one of the only non government
non-space spaces where there's a no fly
zone overhead you can't fly airplanes
over Disney wait that's like so crazy a
lot of interesting factoids about Disney
I'm going to have to listen to this
podcast with you and Olivia no it's
going to be hysterical and we'll just
Jack keep sending in our family
chat she sent this like bedroom
obviously it's like a it literally
looked like AI like if make me a bedroom
for a kid who's obsessed with Mickey
Mouse and it's like the bed is Mickey
and it's like Olivia's new bedroom it's
so funny it's my favorite running joke
in the family and we could not have had
more different weekends no we could not
have what did you do tur deathly ill
from the last podcast you guys heard
Friday morning I was like getting a
little sick oh my God the whole weekend
miserable I haven't left my house since
Thursday how do you feel now not great
you look good I feel you sound good no I
am definitely
sick but I got tested it's nothing like
you know contagious so I got to work
yeah I got to work don't you miss the
days where you're like I'm sick and
everyone's like stay home don't work but
it also made me think like remember when
you used to get sick during the weekends
like as a kid and there was nothing
worse on the planet like my God I
couldn't have gotten sick during the
week now I have to miss my whole weekend
that's how I felt yeah now for us it's
like a holiday falling on a
weekend yes
exactly but and I know we're going to
talk because I'm sure the stories are
about football I watched every minute of
football this weekend and something I
really did want to talk about is me and
Ben have started the OC and we're pretty
deep into it now I'd say we're like 10
or 11 episodes into it and I have an
extremely hot take it's not good
it's not hitting for me the way like
Gossip Girl did I feel like it's kind of
a bad show with you know a lot of
redeeming qualities Sandy K Sandy Kenyon
I mean Sandy Cohen what how far along
are you um so Ryan's living permanently
with them he's been with them for like a
while it's like I'm I would say I'm the
middle of season one cuz I know the
seasons are really long I would say it
takes a while for it to become really
adicting him really good like the
dialogue gets better the characters get
better but I have to say Ben is obsessed
like as some who was watching it the
first time he literally when when I
asked to turn on the football game he
was like so mad he is obsessed and I
know when we go back and watch old shows
we're always like oh you know the main
character is the worst I feel like a lot
of people experience that with Serena
and Gossip Girl I experienced that with
Susan Meyer and with Marissa okay that's
what they Marissa might be worse than
Serena for sure why does nobody talk
about the West wot of all Ryan oh my God
I [__] hate Ryan you would hate Ryan
oh my God and everything he does gives
me the ick like G oh my God I think he's
disgusting like
I Jackie I hate this man heyen Marissa
peret Perfection perfect for each other
the ID annoying people no it's like his
whole life he he gets a chance at a new
life it's time the Summer's over they're
sending him to school he obviously just
can't go to this school he has to take
it's a it's a very prestigious School
takes a placement placement school
placement exam while he's taking the
placement exam summer and Seth are like
Ryan we need you we need to break
Marissa out of the hospital she's upset
her parents are getting divorced and
they want to send her to a facility like
we have to break her
out oh yeah let me throw my whole future
away for this girl I haven't even kissed
yet I can't so dumb so so dumb no
they're a perfect couple cuz she's like
a [__] L like and he has a savior
complex so he keep saving this [__] who
keeps getting into dumb situations okay
in the episode we watched last night I
got the biggest ick from Ryan
when he tried out for the soccer
team and he put on this like soccer
outfit it was like there's something
wrong with
it he was just wearing like really
really long shorts like below his knee
and like this gray t-shirt and he was
running just like such to freak and I
was like G like I just I hate hate and
honestly love Luke so
hot love Luke yeah like he cheated on
her whatever and I know he gets worse
but like love yeah no but he get he gets
better oh oh okay yeah he like he
becomes one of the guys and it's really
killing me just like not to scream
things out at Ben CU like I know the big
things of what happens in the show but I
don't know like the little plot twists
of how we get there but like I just want
to say like I'm just dying to tell Ben
are you loving though Sandy again summer
again Seth again okay I'm so glad you
brought that up best characters in the
show are the Jewish ones sorry and
that's because the creator of the show
who also created Gossip Girl is Jewish
Josh Schwarz that's why there was so
much Judaism in Gossip Girl like nobody
even noticed Sandy and Adam Adam what's
his Seth are the best characters hands
down and it's cuz they're Jewish I'm
telling you now summer is a [__]
[__] and I know she gets better when
she finally falls in love with Seth and
they become a couple y y but she's so
awful like really awful I don't know how
I'm going to like her she's evil you
will it's crazy how you can like she's
the Chuck Bass she is the Chuck Bass
it's crazy how a show can like make you
like someone like someone who you wish
would get killed off eventually you're
like oh they're okay like Adam
Carrington on Dynasty right who did you
ask me Seth sumers Sandy yeah that was
it okay um oh and Julie Coop n Cooper
Julie Cooper by the way Julie Cooper is
in her name is a spoiler alert but right
now she's just Julie Cooper she's you
know thinking about getting divorced
from Jimmy Cooper she's actually so mean
evil she's summer Roberts grown up by
the way so funny she is summer Roberts
grown up and just Ryan was pissing me
off like she does she doesn't want to
live with like screaming like you just
got here you're screaming at the
neighbor that her daughter doesn't want
to live with you anymore like know your
place [__] take a [__] seat like he
insane he and by the way at that point
he hadn't even kiss Marissa like they
just liked each other I can't he's the
worst he's so icky and honestly he's
like short and I don't like him hey not
surprising but funny no but like every
time people rewatch o they're like wait
Marissa was the wor it's like yeah yeah
yeah we need to talk about
Ryan
yeah and I think he's meant to be the
moral compass of the show yes but he's
literally the dumbest [__] alive making
the worst decisions
yeah no I think Sandy Cohen is the moral
compass yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah for
sure so that's the journey we went on
this weekend while I was sick very fun
jolly good time jolly good time jolly
good show yeah jolly good show we do
have a great show as you stated there
was a lot of football so that's our
first story I didn't get to watch the
football but I did watch Liz woods'
Story So I do feel like I was there but
I'm going to tell you everything I watch
every minute of the yeah but I know like
I know who won the G like I've got the
overall picture plus Zach was watching
living room so every time I came out to
you know was a bottle or something I I
checked the score yeah and we listened
to it in the car on the drives um oh wow
yeah it was the least I could do he was
driving nicely okay and I didn't have
you know I didn't need I didn't want for
much Bruno was chilling Bruno came to
Disney too but he didn't come to the
park no but we did see that they had
like a place called like best friend
friend's pet care where you can drop
your pets off cuz I they literally think
of everything wait that's so smart so
smart instead he stayed at the hotel cuz
our hotel was dog friendly we stayed at
the JW Marriott Bonnet Creek and Bruno
was in heaven wait I love that yeah no
and so he got to see the dis he got to
go to Orlando Bruno's extremely well
traveled and cultured and yeah he went
to
Orlando yeah he's extremely cultured and
it wouldn't have been a fun family
weekend without Str no I'm so glad he
got to experience even the littlest bit
of that Disney Magic yeah because even
when you drive like it's Mickey on the
highway sign like Mickey oh my God the
kids were probably freaking yeah except
Harry's car seat has turned backwards so
he he missed all of that what about in
the mirror maybe he saw it in the mirror
maybe he saw it in the mirror but he had
it sun shield up I don't know what he
saw but if he were in the Tesla it's all
sunroof oh and he gets to see a lot but
that's Daddy's Kia for you no you needed
the big family car yeah what do you mean
like a what's a big big family car the
Kia like you could have taken the Tesla
to Disney no no no no oh my God you
sound like Z you needed like the loser
sound being like how could we take the
Tesla like he just wants to like put my
car down because it's so Superior to his
no by the way you should be grateful
like what do you want to [__] up your
car at Disney Let Let the Kia get
[__] up I mean it wasn't like [__]
up but no but it's like hours in the car
with two kids all the stuff snacks of
course like don't do it in the nicer one
I know that's why we need a
minivan that's why if you if you got a
minivan Maybe the shapiros and the wine
ribs could all go together well the
shapiros have a wagon ear and still we
couldn't all go together did you want to
go in one car not to the drive up
because why not have all the space but
we should have maybe gone all in one car
to the
park oh
yeah that was a lesson a lesson so
anyways good times had by all let's get
into the stories without further do
about misar Musa Mickey Mouse oh my that
was like our funniest intro yet I was
cackling the Disney will do that to you
it'll bring out the best of you it's the
joy and the worst so that might be later
in the
episode here are the fast five stories
that you need to know and the fast five
stories that you need to know are
brought to you by hinge the dating app
that's designed to be deleted why well
hinge gives you a sense of someone's
personality and it lets you share your
own you get to know potential dates
through their unique answers to prompts
plus you get a sense of someone's dating
intentions and what they're looking for
and what I like most about hinge from
what I hear from the single gals is like
everyone who's on there their intentions
are to date now You' think that's so
obvious why would anybody go on any
dating app you know without the
intention of dating well it happens
quite a bit actually more than you would
think and everybody on hinge is like
serious about dating meeting someone
getting into a relationship it's not
like a waste of your time if you're
looking for a serious relationship which
I really appreciate yeah no it's for
serious people who want something
serious and you don't want to be wasting
your time time is precious it's a lot to
put yourself out there to put yourself
out on it is get get dressed for a date
a waste of time yeah you want to be
certain that you're putting your efforts
in the right direction yeah and like
what's worse than really like getting
all dressed up spending all this time
going out with someone who's like not
looking for something serious so get off
the app okay right but those people
aren't on hinge which is why appreciate
hinge because everybody on hinge knows
like we're here to meet someone I met my
husband in part thanks to hinge and we
just went to Disney the world yeah I
just by the way I do think that that's
what makes hinge Superior is like the
crop of people who are on it they all
are just like actual people looking for
actual relationships yeah because like
that's how hinge positions itself which
is important right so download hinge and
find someone worth deleting the app for
the hinge app is able to download you
know go do it your future Starts Now
today's episode is also brought to you
by Dermalogica so dermalogica's daily
microfoliant which is an exfoliant from
their skincare line is a favorite
amongst the Dermalogica fans it's
activated with water and it's a gentle
rice based powder exfoliant that
polishes and removes D dulling debris
for smoother brighter skin I'm such a
big fan of exfoliating my skin and I've
used exfoliators that like are pretty
harsh and they leave my skin really red
and I don't even have sensitive skin and
I found the daily microfoliant on Tik
Tok it went kind of viral because it's
like very ASMR you don't just like
squeeze it out and rub it on your face
it's kind of looks like sand almost and
then you put water on it and you rub
your hands together and it like what's
the word I'm looking for um effervesces
if you will and it's like really fun and
cool to use but what's so great about it
it's an amazing exfoliant that you can
use every day most exfoliants since
they're so harsh and like crazy
chemicals in them you can only use them
like two times a week but if you spray
tan a lot like I'm wearing a spray tan
right now you need to exfoliate like
every day exfoliating is a huge part of
your life and I love the daily
microfoliant for face exfoliating it
will bright well for me I really use it
to remove dead skin remove spray tan but
a lot of people use exfoliants for
different reason um it can reduce
blackhead in blackheads improv skin
smoothness visibly brighten skin and
minimize the look of dark spots so
Dermalogica which is a brand we all know
and love I also use their vitamin C
serum is a professional grade skincare
brand whose products are designed to
treat your unique skin concerns so visit
dermalogica.com for more information and
a free gift with over $20 purchase that
check out that's Dermalogica d e r m a l
o g ia.com they're just a skincare brand
like whenever they have a product I'm
like oh I need a new cleanser let me go
to Dermalogica I just trust them they're
made really well a lot of toaster work
there we
stand great thank you so much you're
welcome our first story football
semifinals I think were this weekend it
was the game before the game before the
game yeah it's the game before the
division championships right so
semi-finals then next week would be the
finals no the finals of the conferences
no no I think we would consider this
week like the quarterfinals okay
quarterfinals next week upcoming games
sem and then the Super Bowl so this was
important in terms of who would win the
Packers played the ners and let me say
let me say they gave them a good run for
their money oh my God wait I'm UPS says
have you seen the clip going
viral from this game um this like
enormous defensive player like by the
way the games were so tense like
everybody was fighting like physically
fighting in every game and the Packers
versus ners one like had a lot of
fighting and like people were like
throwing words around and one of the
Packers players like tried to get
involved but this enormous defensive
lineman just like kind of put his hand
out and the player fell to the ground
like just he put no effort Jackie did
you know who the player was the player
who fell to the the ground yeah
Christian mcaffrey no no it was a
Packers player who fell to the ground
yep who do we know except for Aaron
roders the fact that you don't even know
makes the story even greater Simone B's
husband Jonathan owens's like he
literally he went viral cuz the guy
didn't even touch him and he literally
fell completely to the ground stop so
the ners won which was so fabulous there
was so much to take away from that game
and you know the the Packers it was a
close call like not really but you know
the whole time it wasn't like obviously
the Niners are winning like it was a
good game they tried their best that
quarterback Jordan love he's got he's
got his Charis saw an interview with him
he's like he was waiting the theme of
his career is patience because he didn't
start as a quarterback until his
sophomore year in college then he waited
on the bench he waited on the bench as
Aaron roders was quarterback for three
years out of a four-year contract that
he has Jordan love no and like I think
people from the Packers like rodos was
their guy you don't get backtack guys
you know you get a few good years with a
guy you know what they call that instead
of the guy I think they call that a
franchise quarterback yes yes yes which
means like a guy the guy and so I don't
think anybody expected much from him and
he's really fabulous like really really
fabulous yeah and I think like the team
is very young and fresh now and they're
just like killing it no I love that for
them I wish them the most but like not
up against my Niner Gang family you know
no no no no your your watch has ended I
want to say like Jordan love versus
Brock pie like Jordan love was amazing
Brock tury was so bad like he almost
lost the game for for the team yeah Zach
was saying that Brock p is not good he's
not and the thing is he's not a
franchise quarterback he's not meant to
be one I just saw a meme this morning
and it's not a meme it's just a an image
with text on it that Lamar Jackson the
quarterback for the Ravens will make $80
million this year and Brock turo is
going to make 870,000 like he's not a
franchise quarterback no he's not and
the thing is the 49ers team is like so
perfect in every way like George KD Kyle
eek Christian mcaffrey like they've got
the guys Debo Samuels like they've like
the everyone else is doing like level 10
10 out of 10 a plus and they've made it
this far despite the fact that like
really they don't have
quarterback and I know like what
happened with Brock last year was like
Jimmy Garoppolo got injured and this
like fourth string quarterback came up
and he wasn't so bad and it was like
this cool like Jeremy Lynn moment almost
it was like oh cute fun but like why
when the season was over did they not
get a real quarterback like why did
Aaron Rogers go to the 49ers like why
did they get someone because that's what
I was saying if they had Jordan love or
just like someone who's not like the
biggest name but who's like decent they
would just be winning period like it it
wouldn't even be a question and it must
I wonder if everyone on the team is
frustrated like why don't we have a real
quarterback uh it's a good question so
if they don't win the Super bowl or make
it to the Super Bowl it'll be because of
that it won't be because of anyone else
okay that's a good sports analysis so it
was really fun to watch I was really
happy for them but I do worry because
you know they're playing the Lions the
Lions won yesterday they beat the
Buccaneers you know Baker I I I
literally know everything now Baker
Mayfield um he tried and they were the
wild card they shouldn't have even
gotten this far no and they should have
gotten smoked and it was really a
nailbiter to like the last couple of
minutes we we we love when people like
give us you know something to talk about
and I wish them well they did a really
great job and I wanted them to win
because the winner of that game plays
the ners and of course I wanted the
worst team to win but I saw that on your
story but wouldn't you say the team that
wins is the better team I know like
someone could win on a fluke and there's
you know the refs and this and that
things happen but technically like the
team that won would be the better team
regardless of who wins no I don't agree
with that cuz so many rules in football
like make no [__] sense like one I
learned last night a Touchback do you
know that like if you
like run the ball into the end zone but
you
fumble not only does the touchdown not
count you turn over the ball to the
other team but there's a
fumble yeah but like the other yeah but
not not a turnover just a fumble like
you just drop the ball so the the thing
doesn't count you drop the ball when
while you're in the end zone you have to
hold it for how many seconds until a
fumble I don't know but you fumble it
that kind of makes sense why but if you
fumble it on a regular catch you don't
turn it over you just turning it over is
a little messed up yeah yeah okay thank
you that's a tou it's a little stream
yeah no they just like make rules up in
this game every time it's like I don't
know I just just because you win doesn't
mean you're the better team I stand by
that okay that's definitely Up For
Debate I don't disagree but I think you
know it could be a great debate for
someone else so then Detroit and and the
Buccaneers and the debt has been on my
mind a lot lately because the debt
toasters are not like letting this go
and no they're not and they're making a
really good case for the Deb and every
game that the debt wins it's like we
haven't won this game in 60 years and
then the next one 70 years so I do like
the history of it all I think their
shade of blue is a gorgeous shade of
blue I'm so glad you brought that up
it's like pastel it's a really beautiful
shade of blue that I wouldn't mind
seeing on the Super Bowl field I
wouldn't I agree especially if they
played the purple ooh but you
the Super Bowl logo conspiracy theory
very much and it's very much intact
because the Ravens and the Niners are
both in and it's making it you know seem
kind of like a possibility the thing is
though the Deb blue color is not a
primary color so it would never be in
the Super Bowl logo cuz that would be
weird wait but purple's not a primary
color no but the the shade of purple
it's not like they're the
lavenders oh I know what you mean but
also better cuz I was saying it's a hard
blue I said do you really feel like the
NFL is scripted he's like like maybe but
they wouldn't be dumb enough to like
tell you with the logo it's so true like
it could be an Easter egg like they
might have interest like it's definitely
in their best interest to get the Chiefs
to the Super Bowl so many people tuning
in for Taylor their best interest it's
in their best interest so really can't
go we checked her tour schedule oh
that's true actually but maybe she can
make it work she has a plane yeah but
like it's in their best interest to you
know give a good call to the refs over
here like for sure they're not going to
broadcast it in the logo like like
they're not leaving us Easter eggs they
don't want us to figure it out the red
and the logo could be the Chiefs too uh
but there's no purple for them to play
against right exactly so yesterday I was
thinking actually the Buccaneers could
win and then play the ners and then
maybe the buccan ners win
Anders Buccaneers and they're the red
but no they lost they were not the red
no I I don't think anybody feels bad for
the Buccaneers one they were the Wild
Card Mao for even getting to this place
and two They just won a Super Bowl
recently like it's not time but can I
tell you who I actually do feel bad
for who did the debt play no not them oh
them uh the bills the bills the bills
are bills strong let me tell you why I
feel bad for the bills because I was
roing for them I'm not going to lie I do
love an underdog it's a New York team
I'm sorry I'm from New York and you know
that Josh Allen he's got Charisma and
he's got old tweets two things he and I
both have in common and I just I don't
know love for hay Seinfeld yes I kind of
just like love him even though like in
the DMS everybody was making me hate him
like apparently he cheated on his old
girlfriend got a girl pregnant like
I yeah yeah but I'm just sticking to
like my delusional ignorance is
ignorance is bliss and he's a franchise
quarterback like he's a he scored so
many touchdowns like he himself like he
ran with the ball like I'm I kind of
like as I was watching the game was
falling more and more in love with Josh
Allen and the team and they you know
it's like every year they get so so
close but they never really just like
get there and I don't know I was kind of
feeling like maybe it's their year
especially when I you know put them next
to the Chiefs who I'm like no offense
like I'm just like a little bit over I
feel like all we talk about is the
Chiefs and it's Chiefs this and Chiefs
that and they won last year and it's
like always their time and I know
they're amazing but like I'm just like H
like can somebody else get a little bit
of attention yeah like the Chiefs are
whatever the opposite of the underdog is
they are that you know the obvious
choice always winning stays winning it's
annoying Goliath vers David Goliath yes
and a lot of people were saying like
that's very much what it was like for
like 10 years with Tom Brady and the
Patriots and it's annoying it's annoying
like can somebody else have a little fun
yeah I wouldn't have minded the bills
winning either but considering the
Chiefs one we got you know what is also
a big story from the weekend which was
the tailored celebrations of it all yeah
so Taylor was at the game in a sweet
which of course we knew she was going to
be but why was this game different from
all other games well it was the first
playoff game where Travis's brother
Jason was able to attend and not only
did he attend but he got wasted he went
to a tailgate before and he brought his
wife and we were talking last week how
we feel like Kylie Kelce and Taylor SW
like are not friends now they wear in
the suite together and there were a
couple of photos of them talking I don't
think it really proves that they're like
friends no they behaved though but I
feel like Taylor can charm anyone I know
it's like you think you're not going to
like her and then you meet her and she's
just amazing yeah so I feel like they
hit it off they might have not even ever
met up until this point but I I feel
like they click just because I think
it's Taylor's mission to click she's not
going to have a sister-in-law that she
doesn't get along with like she's going
to make everyone like her yeah no and I
think her and Jason got along really
well and I feel like they haven't spent
a lot of time together but when you
think about it kind of reminded me a
little bit of like um in a really like
wrong way how like when before Harry
Prince Harry got married it was like
Harry William and Kate they were like a
thle really and that's really what Jason
Travis and Kylie Kelce have been like
he's been he [__] loves his
sister-in-law and now it's Jason's time
to give that same energy to Travis's new
girlfriend yeah and I feel like he went
in and just like did the most 10 out of
10 and I do feel I always find it
interesting like which friends Taylor
decides to bring to what game and she
brought Cara delvine which like I kind
of thought was weird until I realized
like Cara deline is Jason Kelce like
they're the same okay she is I agree I
thought it was weird one because also
she's not American she cares about
football cuz at first I was like you
should bring your Eagles F friend fan
maybe a friend from Pennsylvania y um
but car deline also is sober now
so we reported that well because she was
not in a good place I she had been
rehabilitated I don't know you know some
people might come off of one thing but
still drink so I don't know what me
nether but it's not the type of
environment for actually no it's not
even about the type of environment but I
think like former Cara deline is more
akin to Jason Kelce than who knows but
even in stilling all the pictures she
like being silly goofy she looked like
her old self like crazy to be drinking
to to be her fun loving self true true
true but I don't know that's a good
question I just always find it
interesting like who gets the invite to
which games maybe it's just based on
availability you know yeah yeah but no
it looked to be like that was the best
Suite in the house I mean it usually is
but they were genuinely having a jolly
good time Britney was there Britney was
there Jackson was there oh I didn't see
him I did they're trying to hide him you
miss him I never miss no they have a
suite full of people to like keep yep
keep Jackson down yeah like it probably
sucks for Britney because I'm sure like
Taylor would get her own Suite you know
but like you know include Britney but
with Britney comes all this baggage
really why does that suck for
Britney cuz it's like oh hey Taylor you
want to go to the game together can I
bring my sex offender brother-in-law
like it's sucks okay but she could split
from him sometimes he could go with
friends no no like she can't that's her
that's like that's Patrick's brother
like no I know but like she's stuck if
you were a football player they are a
package deal if you were a football
player Ben and I would go to a lot of
games together but if sometime like Ben
wanted to go get a suet with the boys
like I could fend for myself okay in
this scenario are you a sex
offender well no no and by the way no
it's like they take a plane there
together they're not going to Charter
two different planes and like these
tickets are like so hard to get they get
one big Suite like for everyone no
Jackson you have to go get another Suite
where the hell is Jackson going to sit
and like that's her brother like you
know like it or not they blood yeah no
but like Ben could get a suite with his
friends and like just throw me a couple
tickets for sure but like you this
analogy is just not congruous because
you are not a sex offender no but
because I'm not a sex offender
like I deserve like it's
less say I was then for sure he's going
to throw me out of the suite and throw
me a couple tickets but considering
we're all good it still wouldn't be
weird that if we don't go to every game
together I don't know like this is a big
game it's not just like a regular season
game that's true I just think it's
interesting so that's the new also
Travis did the heart everyone's losing
their minds so he blew a kiss and then
did the heart after he scored a
touchdown and he scored three honestly
it was one of the cutest things I've
ever seen in my life like sorry like I
loved it it was really cute and it
reminded me of course every touchdown
he's looking at tail like like that's my
girl but it to me that was like his
equivalent of her changing the lyric to
Karma as a guy on the Chiefs it's like
I'm doing this for you in the S I see
you I have eyes only for you by the way
love that analogy thank you and so true
yeah got to make a girl feel special no
it was so cute we got so much footage
Jason Kelsey also like took his shirt
off he was obviously like really drunk
so excited okay also like I I know I'm
crazy but there was like this video
going around of Jason Kelsey like
jumping out of The Suite banging on his
chest whatever and I swear to God I saw
two Spritz cans like I know I know I
sound crazy it looks like there's two
passion fruit Spritz cans where oh I see
them
right now it's worth noting we don't
sell Spritz at that particular stadium
so there's no way they could have bought
it there but when you have a suite and
when you're Taylor Smith like you bring
whatever beverages you like inside the
suite so I'm just saying it's an option
it is I do see something that doesn't
look like part of the the Spritz can but
and Macy Macy who runs the Spritz
Instagram account was also posting on
the Spritz Instagram story he like does
anybody else think that looks like
passion fruit like I wasn't the only one
yeah it does I see them I did like look
at other angles and stuff and like it's
not but let's pretend it is I just feel
like Jason Kel publicly like drinks beer
pounds on his chest but in the privacy
of his own home cracks open as forits
passion fruit for sure I didn't think
necessarily that Jason was drinking that
a lot of people okay that I could see
that for Jason classic CH I could see it
for Taylor of course that's so on the
nose so on the nose um I just had the
best time like watching so much football
I'm kind of obsessed and next week and
you know what I had to cancel all my
plans because I was sick on Saturday
night the night of the ners game 8:15 so
annoying I was actually supposed to be
out at a dinner so you know all well
that ends well and next week both the
games are on Sunday and I have I'm going
to the rodeo this weekend and I actually
moved my flight home earlier so I could
be home but you could watch on the plane
who the hell wants to watch on a plane
like I feel like what else do you do I
always just watch the airplane on my
flight of course me too cuz I'm
sophisticated like that but I just so
close and like oh no but I want to enjoy
like I move my flight home earlier but
I'm excited to go to the
rodeo yeeha tury L this actually is my
first rodeo Zach thought it was really
funny that we call him Brock
pero I call him Brock turty when he
plays bad and Brock T Pie when he plays
good but that's an insult to yourself
that tury would be the negative no right
in this particular scenario I'm us turd
turd as Judy but when it's me turd it
means you know beautiful princess in a
foreign language makes sense to me I
told Zach he should listen to the toast
like we're hysterical and we say funny
things like this all the time oh I'm so
glad you brought that up but what's
funny is that he doesn't listen to the
toast but he listened to my episode of
probably a podcast and he's been like
referencing it all weekend I was just
going to say something about probably a
podcast what were you going to say
Shannon always says like this is a
finance podcast because she gives like
the worst Finance advice she'll like Buy
Herself a new prod bag but then get an
at home manicare yeah yeah no or like
she'll buy herself a new prod bag but
like sell an old one therefore it's free
this is a finance podcast and she's
always saying that when she does like
when she saves $1 she's like oh got a
free Duncan today this is a finance
podcast and so this is a sports podcast
well this is a sports podcast well the
thing this has always been pop culture
Entertainment News podcast if we're
being real and like this is what's going
on in pop culture and entertainment
sorry so yeah we studied up so yeah we
fell in love with the sport okay sue
us Ben wanted to kill me he's like the
game is over like let's go back to
watching the OC and I'm like literally a
man I'm like it's not over there's two
more minutes you're like one of those
debt fans who wouldn't leave the
stadium yeah they were all just like
sitting there being happy also their
quarterback is cute
Jared a cutie we say that about every
quarterback have we ever like discovered
a team and not made mention of like
their quarterback are we against any
quarterbacks no let me think hold on
there's definitely someone I
hate no but see here's the other thing
that gets me confused about football cuz
like you know what's his name the really
hot guy from Cincinnati Joe burrow and
then there's that guy Trevor Lawrence
from did they're franchise quarterbacks
like where are they they get paid like
hundreds of millions of dollars and
we're not even talking about them right
now yeah they didn't even make it and
like Brock pie even though he's not the
greatest with his 870k like I'm sorry he
deserves a raise no I know but like
that's what I don't understand to play
better how you can be worth hundreds of
millions like Joe burrow has the biggest
contract and he's not even we're not
even talking about him right now like
how the [__] does that make any sense no
it doesn't make sense that like these
are the best quarterbacks in the league
and you didn't make the playoff then
you're not the best quarterback in the
league sorry and it's a team sport your
quarterback can be only so good but if
you don't if you spent all your money on
your quarterback and you don't have the
other players yeah but even if you're I
mean look at Tom Brady he's a great
example of the fact that a quarterback
could take you all the way no so true
actually over and over and over again
and he even like went to Tampa Bay just
to prove that point sort of okay respect
respect yeah respect no you're right uh
so I but I agree with you
like like hasht where in the world is
Joe burrow remember all the hoopla for
Trevor Lawrence like no you don't
remember the guy with the long hair oh
my God everyone was obsessed with him he
like married his high school sweetheart
it was actually like super cute and he
was like number one pick and he just
like has his long hair and like big big
contract where are you where are you
yeah and then like we're talking about
two people I never heard of Jared Goff
and love Jordan love like I never heard
of them right makes you think and Zach
was telling me that Brock bero is the
only quarterback in the playoffs right
now who was not draft in the first round
he was the last pick no like it's amaz
it's an amazing story like against I
know he's not good enough but like he is
doing really good and he deserves props
and I think he deserves a raise he
definitely deserves a raise uh somebody
I read somewhere yeah Christian mcaffry
had to buy tickets for his family right
I mean he still makes almost a million
dollars a year like that's certainly not
living below the poverty line but those
tickets are really pricey and Christian
mcaffrey obviously I think he's getting
paid like $50 million a year was able to
you know get some tickets pay for them
for for Brock it's just like not right
that like everyone on the and it might
make him feel some sort of way and so he
drops the
ball so true like he's looking around
like he players he just sees like their
salary and he's like poor pry Lou Jackie
Brock PR is like an IM a man of immense
Faith yeah no like super super Christian
like I feel like he's so religious to
the point where like even if he had
money he would get put it all in the
church plate like I don't think money
does anything for him actually for sure
and like I think his interior life like
is not Guided by money whatsoever but
like then he would have more to give to
the church plate and I think that would
fulfill him more oh that's true maybe he
looks around he says my church is
suffering your churches are
gluttonous and look at me that's what
that's the that's where the resentment
comes from that her church is suffering
P's church is suffering church is
suffering my God we are so funny like
it's insane somebody needs to put us on
ESPN like this is the most funny
conversation that's ever been had in the
history of sports P's church is
suffering someone needs to put us on
ESPN like yesterday okay yeah new we
should oh by the way you know what I
think we should do and I shouldn't say
it out loud cuz we're not going to do it
but we should live broadcast the Super
Bowl yeah like on our YouTube channel
that [__] would be funny 100% you'll be
here yeah but then we miss the Super
Bowl like we could do we could do
something okay patreon exclusive of
course of course patreon.com toast and
that's just our first story
guys are you ready for by the way Jackie
title P's church is
[Laughter]
s oh man I'm sweating are you ready for
our next story
definitely the other bit of content that
was on this weekend SNL which oh I
didn't watch one minute of but two
headlines caught my eye one uh Miss
Olivia Jade was there miss Olivia
Jade this girl is breathtaking this
picture this outfit she's Perfection but
anyway she showed up to support her mans
who was still her mans who hosted SNL so
all that talk last week just flush it
down the toilet and Rachel McAdams made
a surprise appearance to introduced
Renee rap it was Regina on Regina
crime okay back to Story number one
Olivia Jade um told you so just wanted
to say that like we obviously knew these
two were not broken up and just feels
good to be right I agree with you she's
so elegant I [__] love this [__]
like this is like I just only wish good
things for her and dating Jacob a is
obviously like a very good thing it is a
very good thing this picture of her
leaving sax Fifth Avenue and her coat
everything is perfection and it's it's
not a stage like it's not a picture she
took herself and posted to Instagram
like this is a candid moment of a
perfect person no I completely agree I
die for her and now let's talk about
Rachel McAdams who has been like
noticeably absent from all things mean
girls in the last you know year between
Walmart commercial like all these
different things um convenient timing
Rachel McAdams but I'm happy you're
finally getting in on the fun you know
yeah but she didn't interview and she
explained why she was was in the Walmart
commercial and she said she had no idea
everyone was doing it so I feel like
that I could see how that could happen
where it's like oh I got offered to do
like a play an old part in a Walmart
commercial like no thanks and then you
like wake up and it's like oh everyone
said yes and I'm the only one who didn't
do it but that also shows that she
doesn't communicate with her former cast
members which is hurtful to the Mean
Girls fandom I also imagine that they
sent her an offer maybe she didn't know
so she said no and then like when
everybody got on board I'm sure they
like tried one more time to get her on
being like hey everyone's here are you
sure she said she didn't know I I know
it seems like I'm trying to see the
worst in Rachel McAdams I'm really not I
just feel like she's not a
nefarious
person I would agree with that she
doesn't give nefarious energy yeah I
feel like she's very genuine so when she
says something I'm going to believe her
oh wow okay you're just like kind of
taking Rachel McAdams at her word I am
but I give people the benefit of the
doubt until you've lied to me and proven
yourself like to be to be a liar I will
believe what you say I think that's like
a good general rule of thumb I think so
too it's hard like when it's applying it
to people that I don't know right right
it's so important to remember like we
actually don't know Rachel McAdam but
like I get a Vibe even in this picture
she's so excited to be introducing Renee
rap that's not someone who's like
bandwagoning on the Mean Girls Fun
agreed and it's cute like it's the Tina
Fe of it all bringing you know SNL
together Renee rap was great she brought
out Megan the stallion um it was it was
jly good fun I I'm like I'm just a
little angry at Renee rap for leaving
that show like I know it's so dumb but
like I'm angry I know and I do think
it's a mistake and will turn out to be a
mistake but right now it's not looking
that way no of course not because she's
on SNL and she's in like this big movie
yada yada but she left sex lives of
college girls to like focus on music and
because she had a lot going on but like
I don't know you don't just walk away
that show is huge like I think a lot of
people don't realize it's good and like
it really shot her to mainstream success
cuz she was like a Broadway Queen who
not a lot of people knew but not you
know in a mainstream kind of way and I
just think the show will continue to be
huge um and I think it was a mistake
yeah but we'll see CU we didn't even get
a season without her yet so these things
have to play out yeah that's true and
maybe I'm just saying that cuz I'm like
angry because I loved her character and
I just loved like the show was perfect
and I don't want it to change but as
long as as long as Kimberly shalam oh no
what's her name PA Paulina her name is
Kimberly on the show Paulina shalam
remains on the show playing the role of
Dana holsberg I think we're okay I think
so too and that feels good are you ready
for our next story The Big drama from
the weekend you keep saying that about
every show story I said first was like
the big news the the shows this was the
drama what was it kite
baby oh I didn't know if you like knew
about that the name on everybody's lips
is kite baby the CEO is forced to post
two tring apologies after she fired an
employee named Marissa Hughes who asked
to work work remotely while her adopted
premature newborn was hospitalized yeah
so this has been playing out on the
Internet it's really gotten like reach a
level it exceeded the mama Community
everyone's talking and first were even
like the Tik Tok Community like every
everyone is talking about this story so
there was an employee that works for
kite baby kite baby if you don't know is
like one of the leading digital brands
for kids I literally as I'm like reading
this drama I'm unpackaging unboxing a
kite baby order what do you use from
them oh um everything their clothes are
so soft so I love their pajamas I just
got some like outfits that are onesies
and pants for Charlie cuz so it's a
clothing company clothing company really
soft and there you said
digital cuz they don't have stores
they're online oh so you mean like
d yeah but they're like one of the newer
baby Brands that's like everybody love
like that are really getting really big
um
in a DTC DTC that's it that's what I
just said director consumer but okay go
right right but I just need to arrive
there on my own you know what I mean
yeah of course I need to find the word
wider the word I was looking for digital
it's not not digital well they you could
shop online yeah anyways I had just
placed a Kai baby order before this
drama it didn't come until after the
drama and so yesterday I got home and I
was opening everything while like
reading these headlines I'm like oops
but it's it's too soft to return sorry
no by the way whatever is going on
online like you still got to buy the
best thing for your baby like sorry but
I just want you I probably wouldn't have
placed an order in this
moment but while this so you stand you
stand with the employee of course of
course give everyone stands with this
employee okay so give everyone top to
bottom like what the the gist okay so
the employee her name was Marissa she
had been fired after requesting to work
from the neonatal Intensive Care Unit at
a Texas hospital the niku cuz she had
adopted a baby who was born prematurely
the baby was born at 24 weeks and was in
the niku like weighing one pound so of
course girly couldn't go into work she
has to work remotely and instead she was
fired the baby was born at 22 weeks I'm
sorry I mean any sort of company like
not being remotely flexible with their
parental leave when someone's baby is 22
weeks old in a niku like that's when you
go above and beyond for your employees
the fact that it's a company for baby
like is so [__] up like those are the
type and it's a successful one those are
the types of companies that should be
giving you like the crazy I forget who I
was just talking to about this who New
Age benefits where it's like maternity
leave for life oh I was just talking to
a girl who works at Amazon and I was
like what is and she just had a baby I'm
like what do you get three years off
like that those are the types of
companies that should do and she was
like yes those are the types of
companies that should go above and
beyond for uh parental leave because
they can and like kite baby is ex
because they they know what it entails
and she wasn't even asking for her
maternity leave she was asking to work
remotely right and also she should get
maternity leave and I wonder what the
maternity leave policy is for parents
that adopt newborn babies because it's
still you have a newborn at home what is
so she should the she should have been
given maternally not even I mean first
of all her remote work request should
have been granted at minimum yeah but
she also should have been given like
time off or maternity leave and they
should
F sit this girl like everything she's
she seems like the actual sest nicest on
the planet I mean anyone and she by the
way she didn't like want this to like
become national news yeah no but even
she posted like she's not they offered
her her job back she said you know it
would be weird to accept but like her
whole statement was like I'm just
praying for everyone praying for the
company praying that changes our en
acted she's just praying she's praying
and of course they started to Gund me
for her I believe because obviously now
she's you know a new mom without a job
um with Incredible medical expenses for
her new baby right um so like she'll be
okay and I'm sure this is an opportunity
for like a Freeda baby or you know some
company to make make her the CEO or
something like Dreamland baby give her a
call yes somebody needs to give this
girl a job yeah and and they will that
starts in in six years yeah right
right so um like I do think it'll work
as s out but the story became even
bigger because the CEO of kite baby when
this story just like randomly people
started like hearing about it it was
very organic very you know Grassroots
movement around this started to get like
a lot of you know comments on their
social media and so she released a an
apology where she was like reading off
of a script and that like doesn't bother
me so much I think you know with a lot
of people watching you want to be
careful of course um so she had to then
release another apology after that
because people were so angry that she
didn't seem genuine and I just think the
whole story feels so backwards to so
many people cuz it's literally a company
for babies yeah it's just like weird
yeah I mean the last kite baby order
that I now that we're just slamming kite
baby um I ordered kite baby stuff like
maybe 6 months ago and it like never Shi
like it was like two weeks and it hadn't
shipped and they're like we're moving
warehouses so I I was like can I just it
was almost a month I was like can I
cancel my order so I never even got it
and then I decided to take a chance on
them again this time cuz how good the
stuff is I was like okay I'll wait
whatever it is with your warehouse and
this happens oh my God kind of like you
are the you catalst for drama at kite
baby you are the common denominator here
they can't handle my orders they can't
handle your they can't handle your kids
like no it's really crazy so this was a
shock to everyone I think that they'll
be
okay yeah like you know this happens the
life cycle of Brands I mean people are
shopping at Balenciaga again so like you
know this is and I think things will
hopefully be okay for Marissa the
employee she has her go fun me and she
has so much support and love and prayers
and everyone's like she's you know the
name lips and I hope that things work
out for her too but she obviously has a
lot on her plate right now I don't think
she cares about the the the internet
like she's in the NICU like there are
more important things in the world than
like what's going on in your Instagram
right but it's just been a crazy Saga
and has and it's been crazy the amount
of like reach the story has how far it's
gone yeah yeah surprising considering
kite baby isn't the biggest name in B
it's not like Johnson and Johnson right
right kind it's kind of like the Johnson
and Johnson of the digital age of DTC
digital yeah for sure yeah for sure are
you ready for our fourth story if it's
the fourth story that's brought to you
by Thrive Market is wow so Thrive Market
is our go-to for all of our grocery and
household essentials and the convenience
of getting everything online and then
quick quickly shipped to our doorstep is
a huge timesaver we love that thrive
Market carries brands with the highest
quality ingredients and sourcing methods
so they restrict hundreds of ingredients
across their food and cleaning
categories so we can use their onsite
on-site filters to suit our lifestyle
needs whether you're looking for kids
snacks that are organic low sugar
Alternatives gluten-free Pantry
Essentials you can basically curate your
own shopping experience with a few
clicks and as a Market member you're
going to save money on every single
grocery order on average you save about
30% each time they even have a deals
page that changes daily and always has
some of our favorite Brands Jackie I
know with all the kids in your house you
get like three Thrive Market deliveries
a week I do I actually have one in rot
it should be here today I love it for
healthy snacks for me for the kids I
when we're going to Disney I can just
grab a bag of Puffs that I got from Fri
Market I know that they're not going to
like be filled with sugar and make the
kids crazy but they will be like
exciting treats for them like a nice
Annie's cheddar smile from from Thrive
Market there's nothing better for Mama
and for baby so join in on the savings
with Thrive market today and get 30% off
your first order plus a free $60 gift go
to thrivemarket.com
theeast for 30% off your first order
plus a free $60 gift that's th i v
market.com theeast thrivemarket.com
theeast when you join Thrive Market
you're also helping a family in need
with their one forone membership
matching program today's episode is also
brought to you by ag1 taking care of
your health isn't always easy but it
should be simple and that's why drinking
ag1 every day no exceptions is such a
great way no cap No Cap but you cap on
your AG one no but I it's it's not in
this ad copy but ag1 is busing
c c so it's one scoop mixed in water
once a day every day and it can make you
feel energized focused nourished strong
ready to take on the day people have had
everybody uses ag1 for different things
a lot of people use it for digestion a
lot of people use it for energy for
focus and it's really such a great thing
to add to your routine how you start off
your day is like really setting the tone
for how you're going to feel the rest of
the day and having really good things in
your morning routine like drinking ag1
will set you up for Success you're
getting essential brain gut and immune
health support with vitamins probiotics
and nutrients from Whole Foods if
there's one product we have to recommend
to elevate your health it's ag1 and
that's why we've partnered with them for
so long if you want to take ownership of
your health start with ag1 try ag1 and
get a free one-year supply of vitamin D3
and K2 and five free ag1 travel packs
with your first purchase exclusively at
drink a1.com toast that's drink a1.com
toast check it out thank you you're
welcome are you ready for our next story
I am Southern Charms Craig Conover and
Austin croll are set to open a new bar
Concept in
Charleston of course genius the Southern
Charm boys are bringing new business to
town in the form of a neighborhood
Tavern fit for friends fans and tourists
later this year there will be more
to in Charleston South Carol
Carolina did you write that or no and I
need to thank Entertainment Tonight
online for putting that in that's funny
because that was really
good it's EAS it's good e like the birds
in the be and
two so anyways Entertainment Tonight can
exclusively announce it's Southern Charm
Stars Craig and Austin are bringing a
new business to their adopted Hometown
partnering with Uptown Hospitality Group
on a fresh concept called by the way
wait is Uptown Hospitality Group Leva no
hers is like Republic or something yeah
I don't think she's Uptown because she's
not named in this article oh okay the
neighborhood Tavern is set to open
Midsummer just around the corner from
the company's Flagship location Uptown
social on the city's famous King Street
this move furthers Craig and Austin's
business relationship the two are
already Partners in a podcast called
pillows and beer and inv ters in New
York City eery called Carriage House
Craig said Charleston has grown so much
in the last few years and brought in a
lot of Travelers so we wanted to create
a space where locals and travelers could
hang out together and enjoy the
neighborhood Travelers is an interesting
word yes I completely agree I believe
the word Craig was looking for was
tourist but I think he it was a choice
not to use it cuz I feel like tourist is
a little offensive it's derogatory right
why because like nobody wants to go to a
place where the tourists are at like
avoid I go where The Travelers go right
I have to say this is like pretty
brilliant on behalf of um Craig and
Austin the show is so big it's so
popular I do feel like it's done a lot
for Charleston and when you think about
like how the restaurants in West
Hollywood for vaner prump rules and Real
Housewives at Beverly Hills what that
did for like the lives of the reality
stars and their businesses this is that
I think I'm like a smaller scale but I
think it's really smart um I do Wonder
like what Shep makes of like all of like
the Dynamics within the the friendships
of the men like Chang in so much and now
Austin and Craig for like the last
couple of years their podcast is really
successful they went on tour like what
what he makes of that well there's a few
things one I think at one point Shep is
part owner in a bar or he has his own
bar in Charleston he doesn't like talk
about it that much on the show but he
does something like this I don't know
what's going on with the bar but I also
think it's interesting that this bar
isn't branded as like a southern charm
thing it's it could have been called
pillows and beer and it's not I was
thinking that what's it called by the
way BTW so it has nothing to do with the
show it could have been called
B right I guess TomTom has to do with
the show pump has to do with the show
they all like they all do typically so
it's not but I think it's also smart
that way if Southern Charm goes away say
doesn't make the bar irrelevant they can
use Southern Charm to prop up the bar
but it's not like just a bar for Bravo
fans and people might not walk down the
street they might not want to go in
they're like oh I don't watch that show
that's the bar from the show but it
really can be more inclusive and it's
just an in I'm sure they sat on it for a
long time and thought about it and came
to this decision as the best decision so
I do think it's interesting but yeah
Austin and Craig it's also funny cuz on
the show sometimes they fight like they
don't like each other like brothers
though no but like they'll go through
spells where it feels like they're not
talking but they are business partners
and I feel like they prioritize their
business relationship like no matter
what happens in the personal like we
will be business partners and I feel
like at this point in their lives
they're more of business partners than
they are of friends at certain points
yes but they're also like professional
reality stars and maybe they're able to
like really compartmentalize like what
happens on the show as like that's part
that's work you know and not being like
actual personal drama I feel like it's
kind of the opposite where when they're
not filming they
like really not that they're not friends
but like they're not each other's maybe
best friends in this world that's good
though and then when they're filming
like they just get picked right back up
when they do their podcast they're
touring like they're really it feels
like very good business partners and
then maybe not all the time like BFFL
BFF living together I do like I think
one of my favorite sort of storybook
ending character Arc you know Journeys
through all reality TV is like how Craig
Conover really like ended up on top yeah
with you know Paige in his relationship
professionally he did become a lawyer
sewing down south is huge it's huge no
the the tone of the show has changed now
that Craig isn't the punching bag and
the last season so last season and this
season it's like everybody is like
struggling with how to treat him and
they and they like to be like you've
changed since you're shut up jealous you
just have to have respect now you can't
get away with you have to take him
seriously yeah yeah it's funny watching
everyone try like have to like struggle
with like Craig isn't the butt of the
joke anymore like jokes on them I love
that no I love it as someone who has
always loved Craig and like thought that
he's been right and mistreated it's so
vindicating I imagine how Craig feels no
totally yeah no but his relationship
he's winning everyone else is like a
mess Austin's a mess Shep is a mess
Whitney M and you just you just love to
see it like it's my favorite thing and
this is just like one step further of
like them becoming really businessmen of
Charleston I'm sure Shep will find a way
to knock it but it's impressive I agree
and no one's done it on that this
particular show yet like you said he has
a bar but I like I didn't know that
except for Le but leva's kind of like
the Lisa Vander had it before but now
her bar has a
show yes what's it called again Southern
Hospitality I I've not seen it but it
looks good and it looks like it was good
it was good it makes total sense yep yep
yep yep so so does this and I hope it
does well me too and like maybe they'll
get a show next you know like yeah it's
getting TomTom yeah until it isn't
hopefully it's well run yeah tomtom's
well run also it's smart that they're
working with a Hospitality Group they
can lend their faces and stuff but like
maybe not have all the pressure not be
like tomw and S who put all their money
into it and like refinance their houses
yep so it looks like they're making
shwed business moves and you love to see
it you do but what is surprising that I
was thinking about is the fact that
Austin laun
trp yes I think it's still around but
the fact that he found no way to use
momentum from the show in order to like
it remains like a local IPA only
available in Charleston yeah yeah at
like two bars yeah they could have named
the bar trop pop which is honestly I
think troop's such a good name and like
that's what they could have named if
they wanted it to be like the Southern
Charm bar which they don't yes yes yes
yes yes which I think is um good
positioning I hope I hope they have
success I agree our fifth and final
story is that Kim Kardashian attended a
boss mitvah this weekend I'm obsessed I
saw so Kim attended the bot Mitzvah of
her lifer friend's daughter and she was
posting from the bot Mitzvah which look
do we know which lifer friend it was I
couldn't figure it out but I'm sure
others could me neither so Kim has this
group of friends they call themselves
The lifers they're like OG friends from
middle school obviously everybody knows
Allison the blonde girl who's like
always around she's a lifer Zoe wrinkler
Henry wrinkler win Winkler Winkler's
daughter Henry Winkler daughter is a
lifer it's like this group of like seven
or eight girls and one of their
daughters had bought Mitzvah and like
I'm obsessed yeah Kim was posting um
some of the activations what was the
girl's name um Violet I think violet she
had like a little Starbucks Violet
stares then little skims it was like a
little Mall pop up it was really cute
she also posted a video of violet doing
the Hora Kim said I love the hor # I
love the hor # um mother of the B
mitzvah
yep also I love the Hora no the Hora is
such a good like it's such a good energy
like Vibe cultivator Vibe cultivator it
makes me sad that people have like
weddings that don't have Horas because
to me the horror is my favorite part and
it's so rooted in Tradition you know
like we've they've been horing for
thousands of years in the land of Israel
where the Jews are the indigenous people
agree
so I'm glad that Kim got to experience a
good horror also this bot Mitzvah girl
was like so elegant beautiful not
awkward B mitzah Energy well she's from
Hidden Hills and Kim Kardashians at her
B so like she wasn't going to be brace
face like she about the brace face the
way she carried herself this bosm misah
okay but also it's worth noting that
like bosm misah aged girlies today are
not what they were in the days of your
like 13 is 13 no no it's not you don't
know this no
are doing things differently but
biologically it's Evolution no it's
Evolution no it's not it's it's uh
social change it's not biological change
mentally on the outside they might look
different but on the inside they're the
same I don't
agree 13 is 13 awkward teens are awkward
teens I know they look different but on
the
inside they're going through all all the
same feelings that you were
La they're not what are they feeling
well today they're feeling depressed and
suicidal they really are that's true
like they're built different they're
like experiencing such different
childhoods than we were they're all
depressed it's so negative like Oh I
thought you say how like now
13-year-olds like look like you know
18-year-old inst super models well they
do also look different because they have
access to more information than we do
and more like makeup tutorial
like they know what they're doing maybe
invisaline Invisalign too yes but this
is a huge conversation happening on Tik
Tok right now it's like all about the
10-year-old to go to Sephora and like a
lot of these seph Sephora employees are
speaking out because they're the kids
are so [__] rude and like disgusting
they like play with the displays and
like make it dirty and they really all
go over to the drunk elephant um section
the kids today are obsessed with drunk
elephant moisturizer bronzing drops Etc
and then people started to realize if
you look at the ingredients in drunk
elephant drunk elephant is not made for
kids it's just a brand that's weirdly
like kids have become obsessed with and
it's kind of like a Liv strong bracelet
like if you don't have it you're not
cool so these kids like force their
parents to take them to Sephora and
force them to go get drunk elephant but
if you look at the ingredients it has
like retina in it it's really for mature
skin it's not for kids and this
conversation of like does you know drunk
elephant is there a responsibility on
the brand because if you look at it it
really kind of looks like a brand for
kids it's like bright colors it's like
looks like a toy almost it's like pump
screw like okay but it's also called
drunk that's not for kids so then the
other side of the conversation is like
well one it's called drunk this is
obviously not a brand that's ever
marketed towards kids two like the child
the kids industry like doesn't have a
monopoly on bright colors like just
because something's colorful doesn't
make it for kids so there is this big
conversation about like is drunk
elephant guilty but you're right like
drunk being in the name like it's
obviously not for kids you know what
that reminds me of Jewel like the kids
industry doesn't have a monopoly on
fruit woo so true yeah jewel
literally gone but not forgotten but the
thing is there was there was evidence of
jeel marketing towards teens I don't
think there really is evidence of drunk
elephant marketing towards kids no no
I'm sure they're like how did we end up
in this situation like where where it's
like every 13-year-old yeah but a lot of
the jewel I'm sure like there might be
evidence of like Jewel marketing
campaign like targeting kids but like a
lot of the citations were like it's
fruity yes right which really isn't an
argument fruit isn't inherently childish
no Everybody Eats fruit like everybody
wants a fruity pebble something right no
it's true but that's what people are
talking about on Tik Tok that and kite
baby okay so now you're in the now and I
just loved this episode and I want to
end it so we can get it out because
people deserve to hear this I agree and
it's been a long one right yeah we're at
like an hour 20 okay let them go turtle
thank you guys so much for listening to
the toast millania Morning Show where we
deliver the past five stories you need
to know everybody Friday on YouTube
you're watching this on YouTube please
don't free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also AV podcast
podcast T we are have an amazing Monday
and we'll see you tomorrow for Tuesday
because that's how it works that's how
it works love you
bye